hey what's going on guys it's Rob I am
not dead I am still alive and I know
I've been m.i.a for almost two months
now the last video I released was the
super boomerang video Wow
back in August August 31st basically and
that went over pretty well with my
subscribers I got a lot of new
subscribers from that I think since I
put out that video I've gained over
5,000 subscribers so I'd like to say
thank you guys so much for the support I
really appreciate it and hello to my new
subscribers thank you very much for
watching my videos and I hope you enjoy
them so you're probably wondering like
what I've been doing for the last two
months well I've been juggling apples
Oh
Oh
that was like two weeks ago I went apple
picking and had a good time but look at
the size of these apples they are the
size of grapefruits I mean it's gigantic
so I'm in my second year of dental
school now and this month has been
pretty hectic I've had quizzes exams and
practicals every single week but I just
recently finished a whole bunch of
midterms I had like three in a row and I
finally have this weekend off that I can
actually kind of relax and I decided to
update you guys cuz I hate to leave you
hanging you know what this stuff on my
face is actually getting pretty icky and
annoying so I think I'm gonna shave it
off right now my must get rid of every
single hand my head even these here much
better come on man we don't care about
your face Rob we just want to see your
cat you want to see Lila hmm you don't
care about Beauty ball you just wanna
see my cat now
Lila what are you doing ah hi
Lila where's the laser what is a laser
it's a laser thanks again for all the
feedback in the comments in the
moderator and also in the comment
section I have been reading through them
and it seems a lot of people really want
to see the magic ball the origami magic
ball now I have never really completed
one but I do know how it's made so I'll
consider it even though it'd probably be
a really long tutorial I've also been
meaning to do like a juggling tutorial
show tying tutorial and an origami tips
video where I'm going to go through some
of the frequently asked questions in
some of my models like the flapping bird
how to make it flat or how to join the
two pieces of the ninja star how to fill
up the water balloon and possibly
clarify some parts of the origami
boomerang and also I don't know if you
guys have ever seen something like this
but this is known as the transforming or
eight-pointed ninja star and I've gotten
a few requests for this so it basically
starts out as like an octagon shape and
then it becomes this so it's pretty cool
and I've been thinking of making a
tutorial about this so let me know
what's your first choice down in the
comments section below in the future I
really want to do some more with my
channel and my viewers like make some
t-shirts do some video contests and
giveaways ways to get you guys more
involved and a way that I can actually
give back to you guys
also so thank you guys very much for
watching and here's what some people
said on the super boomerang video
ninja come here come here sit sit down